petrocotin says ukraine zaparisia
nuclear plant faces a serious danger of
radioactive meltdown he says he believes
the russian military occupying the plant
is shelling it to disconnect it from the
ukrainian power grid and reconnect it to
a power system in russian-controlled
crimea taking all the power with it
they have already cut three of the four
connections to the ukrainian grid he
says and if they sever the fourth that
poses a serious nuclear risk
is a risk of
losing the external power to the plan
and it is dangerous because
there will be then
blackout mode and they will be starting
diesel generators and
if they stop then you will have like
melting of
the nuclear core of reactors
he's asking for the plant to be declared
a demilitarized zone monitored by the
international atomic energy agency out
of control of the russian army
the foreign ministers of the g7 group of
industrialized nations agree they say
it's russia's presence at that plant
that's endangering it and they've issued
a statement demanding that russia leave
and turn over control to ukrainian
authorities
the russians in turn blame the
ukrainians for putting the plant at risk
by firing on the facility
britain's defense ministry predicts the
invasion is about to enter a new phase
with the heaviest fighting shifting 350
kilometers to the front line that
stretches from zapposia to herson
nearby in battle scarred mikolayev
residents have emerged from a 54-hour
curfew
they've come out to queue up for water
and food in a region that's been the
target of russian bombs since the
invasion began in february
ludmila statifa is among the thousands
of displaced people evacuating
chevchenkova village near hasan now
under russian control
the daily bombardment is taking its toll
of course people are afraid but everyone
is hoping that they will not reach us
and things will get better but many
houses in our village are destroyed and
people have died
there are a hundred fifty thousand
people in the city and the red cross
says all need some kind of help john
hendren al jazeera keith
for further analysis let's bring in
michael black who is the director of the
center for nuclear engineering at
imperial college london he joins us from
there hello there michael thanks so much
for being on this newshour i want to
begin with the current status of the
plant
information has been difficult to verify
but it appears the facility has been
attacked several times now what are the
implications of that
as i understand it the the attacks
haven't actually directly struck the
reactors themselves and
principally being
ancillary buildings and also the power
lines that feed the reactants provide
the reactors with power to function
okay so now we're hearing that russia
has been able to or is working towards
redirecting the power
to crimea given the vast
area between the two
areas for want of a better word how are
they able to do that
well
it's not that difficult electricity can
be transported i mean most countries
have grids the electricity you get comes
from a a
power plant
uh perhaps hundreds of kilometers away i
don't think that's that's a problem i
think the concern
if there is any is
uh that it may interrupt the offside
power to the
um to the reactors and i think as was
pointed out in your report prior to
um prior to this
you you need that power to maintain
cooling to the reactors
there are backup systems so as we
mentioned the diesel generators that
will kick in
should offsite power be stopped and as
long as they function
then everything's fine
i suppose i suppose it's it's
encouraging that the russians want to
use the electricity that does imply that
they don't want to damage it but you
never know
yes it's certainly a dynamic situation
so michael if they're able to redirect
that electricity and as you're saying
it's relatively simple to do that
what impact would that have on the
energy supply to europe
well obviously
they're in control of that energy supply
um and and so so europe would would get
less and it's already struggling so
it's an issue but but as i understand it
most of the reactors aren't running
haven't been running i don't think
europe is depending on it at this point
it has bigger problems with regard to
the energy crisis possibly than than the
suffragette
reactors
right and given the current moves by
russia
do they violate international protocols
and what would happen if this behavior
continues
i think there is a great concern that
the nuclear reactors are run very
carefully according to strict protocols
and um
as as i understand it this is being
managed by russians and it's ukrainians
that are keeping the reactor going um
it begs the question whether
the proper maintenance schedule
schedules are being carried out and
repairs are being carried out the
day-to-day maintenance that's not
happening then you do start to worry
that backup systems for instance might
not function when they're needed so it
would be it would be a huge an important
step if the
russians would allow the iaea some
access just in order to assess the
situation
okay well we appreciate your insights on
this issue michael black black the
director of the center for nuclear
engineering at imperial college london
thank you thank you